Donald Trump has been humiliated after
teasing a major announcement and the
major announcement is Trump digital
trading cards including one where Trump
is dressed like an astronaut
I uh I don't know how else to explain it
all day Wednesday it was being teased
that on Thursday Trump was going to make
a huge announcement
and speculation was is he dropping out
of the race
is he announcing who his vice president
is going to be no the announcement
posted to Trump's truth social
was as follows major announcement my
official Donald Trump digital trading
card collection is here
these limited edition cards feature
amazing art of my life and career
collect all of your favorite Trump
digital trading cards very much like a
baseball card but hopefully much more
exciting go to collecttrumpcards.com and
get your cards now only ninety nine
dollars each would make a great
Christmas gift don't wait they'll will
be gone I believe very quickly this is a
complete and total humiliation a former
president of the United States running
again teases a major announcement and
the announcement is digital trading
cards one in which Trump is dressed like
Superman one in which he's dressed like
an astronaut and a bunch of others that
are just completely bizarre and pathetic
Trump's major announcement teas is for
release of digital card collection
writes Brett Samuels for the hill while
some speculated the announcement would
be related to the speaker race playing
Out Among House Republicans or Trump's
largely inactive 2024 presidential
campaign it was instead about a new
money-making outlet for the former
president
Trump boasted about the cards sales are
not affiliated with the campaign the
reveal elicited mockery from liberals
and disbelief from conservatives folks
look at this website we are on
collecttrumpcards.com there is a
sweepstakes each digital trading card
nft is not only a rare collectible it
automatically enters you into a
sweepstakes for a chance to win
thousands of incredible prizes and meet
the one and only number 45. the cards
are only 99 each and uh
you need a wallet
folks what the hell is going on it's
almost 2023 I don't think I would have
guessed that Trump would be running for
office but not campaigning not leaving
his house but making sweaty speeches
that require a hundred takes to get
right while promoting digital trading
cards I didn't have that on my bingo
card I will admit but
it's going to be a wacky Year I hope all
of you will be with us make sure you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel and
folks Friday December 23rd okay year-end
membership special
huge discount your first month's payment
will be donated to charity okay this is
we've we've never done something like
this is before and it's going to be
absolutely fantastic okay
you get on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com
Friday the 23rd you'll get an email
saying
here's how you get a membership
with a large discount
you become a member you get all the
membership benefits including the bonus
show the bonus show where you want to
make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves you get
all of that
we take your first month's payment
and donate it to charity I will be
saying more about the charity uh next
week but basically
we're sending people cash it's a charity
that sends people cash which I believe
is the best way to actually help people
get on the newsletter at
davidpackman.com more info next week
before you go if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more please make sure to
subscribe to my YouTube channel you can
click the Subscribe button below or
above or wherever it is on your screen
and if you want to support my work even
more strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description